[موسيقى
] للرقص الشرقي الكثير من الباليه
في أسلوبه ، ولا أشك حقًا في
القرار الذي اتخذته عندما قررت
المجيء إلى تونس ، لقد كان مثل
الحلم من نواح كثيرة ، تمتلئ إفريقيا
بالمواهب الفنية والجمال
اسمي أمين علي ، أنا
راقصة شرقية محترفة من تونس
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
الرقص الشرقي الذي يسمى أحيانًا الرقص الشرقي
له جذور عميقة في
الثقافات الشرقية أمينة علي هي إحدى الفنون
الرائدة في الرقص الشرقي ، إنها في
الواقع الكثير من أساليب الرقص الشرقي  الرقصات على
سبيل المثال في تركيا ، هل يرقصون جانبًا واحدًا من
Leoben له أسلوب آخر
ومصر لديها جانب آخر درسته ،
لذا فإن الرقص الشرقي المصري هو
أسلوب أحبه في الغالب لأنني أشعر أنه
أكثر هدوءًا ولدت وترعرعت في النرويج ،
كانت أمينة متصلة دائمًا  بالنسبة
لتراثها التونسي عبر الولايات المتحدة ، لدي
أم متوسطة وأب فينيقي
لأن أبي عربي ، نسمع الكثير
من موسيقى إنكا الرغوية والموسيقى العربية في
منزلنا ، لذا كانت هذه الموسيقى تؤثر علي
بشكل إيجابي للغاية ونرقص دائمًا في
حفلات الزفاف حفلات الزفاف العربية في النرويج ،
على الرغم من أن أمينة كانت منجذبة للرقص الشرقي ،
فقد درست الطب في الأصل لأن
شغفها بفرقة الرقص أمينة حولتها
إلى مهنة بدوام كامل تدرس
الرقص في إسبانيا لتصبح قائدة
لاستوديو رقص نرويجي
وانتقلت في النهاية إلى تونس ،
عرض علي أحدهم عقدًا للرقص
مع موسيقيين حيين في مطعم في
فترة شهرين ، ثم
اكتشفت أن لدي إمكانية
البقاء لأنني نصف تونس لذلك
قررت البقاء لأنني  أحب
تونس وهي بلد مدهش من عدة نواحٍ
مركز حركة عبر القارات
ظهرت أمينة في مقاطع فيديو موسيقية في التلفزيون التونسي
العديد من الحفلات الموسيقية
[موسيقى]
في خضم الأداء على خشبة المسرح
وعلى الشاشة لا تزال أمينة تركز على
تعليم الرقص الشرقي أيضًا
[الموسيقى]
يعتبر أداء وتعليم الرقص الشرقي جزءًا من كونك راقصة باليه
، فهذا
شيء مختلف حقًا عن
مهنة الرقص
الشرقي ،  إنها حياة مليئة
باللمعان والفرح ، لا يعني ذلك في الواقع
أنك ربما تكون على خشبة المسرح ثلاثين دقيقة
ولكن لديك 24 ساعة في اليوم حيث
يتعين عليك القيام بالعديد من الأشياء ، لذلك كل يوم أذهب
إلى البنك أذهب إلى الخياط الأول  اذهب
إلى المركز لشراء القماش ، هناك العديد من
الاستعدادات حول الرقص اليوم
تستعد أمينة لأدائها
كعرس تونسي مما يعني قضاء
وقتًا أطول لتصفيف الشعر والمكياج أكثر مما
كنت أتمنى حقًا ألا
أضطر إلى إنفاقه  الكثير من الوقت على الماكياج
والأزياء ، لكن كراقصة استعراضية ، عليك
أن تقضي الكثير من الوقت في هذا حتى تكون
مستعدًا للعرض
الذي هو مجرد جزء منه وآمل أن
أنتهي قريبًا وبعد ذلك سأقوم بإصلاح
شعري.  أنا متحمس للغاية
[موسيقى
] أسوأ شيء هو الجلوس وانتظار
هذا العمل ، عليك الانتظار كثيرًا
بين العرض بعد كل الانتظار ،
إنه وقت العرض
في تونس ، أشعر حقًا أن
معظم الأشخاص الذين قابلتهم موسيقيين وجميعهم
أيضًا  الناس العاديين الذين لا
يرقصون  إي تحترم فن
الرقص الشرقي لدرجة أنهم يرون الفن حقًا على
أنه فن وليس فقط راقصة ملهى
ومهمتي هي أن أظهر للناس أنه
فن ورياضة جيدة جدًا لجسد الأنثى
[تصفيق]